hey welcome to geek culture explained
cutting back at it with a conversation
that I'm certain will be ruffling a few
feathers and uh you know depending on
who you ask ladies and gentlemen
conversations that ruffle feathers may
be the only convos worth having so since
the release of Thor love and thunder
I've seen something I thought I never
would now I'm not a full-blown Alex
Jones level conspiracy theorist but I do
like to soak in as many perspectives and
ideas as possible so I can utilize my
human consciousness to form my
perspectives and there's a conspiracy
theory that the Large Hadron Collider
which recently resumed operations has
tampered with space-time and thus
launched us into alternate realities
just not in a dramatic earth-shattering
way that where we'd be physically
cognizant of it and honestly that may be
the only credible explanation for what
I've witnessed people in droves taking a
social media to negatively critique the
MCU publicly
saying all kinds of wild things such as
store love and thunder makes Thor the
Dark World look like a masterpiece how
phase four is collectively ruining the
MCU and even comparing the MCU to fast
food now the prodigiously small amount
of you who may be familiar with some of
my previous work over the years will
recall that I said the MCU was like fast
food back in 2019. now keep in mind that
was over three years ago when the MCU
was at its Zenith coming off Avengers
end game as you can imagine it was an
immensely unpopular thing to say at the
time my perspectives even spawned a
bunch of troll accounts on Instagram who
were honestly more committed to me than
any woman I've ever dated you just had
to be there I recorded that podcast
episode immediately after Kevin feige
unveiled the future of the MCU at San
Diego Comic-Con 2019 which interestingly
entailed everything coming out of phase
four notwithstanding the fact that I
really may be a pop culture profit I
made that fast fruit critique based off
my own experience with the MCU up until
that point it's also important to note
that saying the mcu's like fast food is
not a wholly negative critique right
there's been plenty of days when I was
feeling like utter trash and the only
thing that was able to console me was
2500 calories from Taco Bell no one can
deny that fast food is scrumptious but
should your diet consist entirely of it
it's perplexing to me that phase four is
a reason many people started to dissect
and reevaluate their relationship with
the MCU because the writing has always
been on the wall for quite some time in
my opinion while the films give you cool
cultural moments what are MCU films
ultimately saying because at a certain
point ladies and gentlemen cool things
happening is not a sustainable model for
any art form not in literature not in
video games and certainly not in movies
the mythical Marvel formula is still
very much such an effect it may just
have a different skin largely because of
the addition of Disney Plus for further
context the entirety of the infinity
Saga which spans phases one two and
three consisted of 49 hours and 56
minutes across the films phase 4 alone
has 50 hours and 21 minutes between the
films and Disney plus and at the time of
this recording we're not even done with
phase 4 yet which ladies and gentlemen
brings us to the central question of
this video is the MCU diluting itself
now before you think I'm being too
negative I have a simple ask just close
your eyes for a second and visualize
your favorite childhood movie that might
be getting a modern day reboot think
about your favorite film that got a
sequel that was unable to capture the
magic of what made the original so
endearing think about your favorite TV
show that went on for too many seasons
and progressively became less
interesting the act of diluting has a
fascinating recurring role within
entertainment and logically speaking
dilution is only possible if you've
built yourself up to a position of
cultural influence and impact you can't
dilute that which was never strong to
begin with and I want to remind you of
the MCU started from a single film and
built its way up to accomplishing
something that's never been done in the
history of film actually scratch that
the history of entertainment there's a
term coined by a political scientist
named Joseph Nye called Soft power the
easiest way to describe it is the
opposite of something like physical War
which you can imagine is a form of hard
power culture for example would be an
example of soft power Hollywood
professional sports hip-hop all examples
of American soft power Kanye once once
said that America's greatest export is
entertainment and being Indian it's
truly perplexing to me that so much of
the youth growing up in India has more
interest in the lore of the MCU than of
their own cultural mythology I say that
all the contextualize just how
gargantuan of a shift it is for all of
entertainment if the public starts
critiquing the MCU and demanding higher
quality from it the recent outcry about
Marvel Studios relationships with visual
effects houses further adds Credence to
the point of this video also this is not
a money conversation if you're a tour to
anything I say in this video is that
Karan the MCU is a cash cow between
theatrical revenue and Disney plus
subscribers then I fear you have missed
the point of this debate entirely let's
go a bit deeper Disney plus launched on
November 12 2019 and of the 10 things
Kevin feige mapped out during Comic-Con
that year five of them were Disney plus
entities so to bolster a new streaming
service the MCU took a very huge gamble
of fragmenting it's audience the
expectation now was that because you
would get more MCU content you'd consume
more MCU content I wish I could be a fly
on the wall during those meetings
because you have to wonder who raised
The Logical point that what if someone
who was deeply invested in the MCU films
was not able to keep up with the content
coming out on Disney plus wouldn't that
jeopardize the quote-unquote connective
tissue the MCU Prides itself on was it
just sheer hubris by Disney and
believing that people would consume
every bit of MCU related content that
was given to them if that wasn't hubris
what about believing that people love
the MCU so much that they would never
dare criticize it on the scale they have
since the release of Thor love and
thunder objectively speaking ladies and
gentlemen the release of Disney plus
fragmented the MCU audience you have a
segment who went into Multiverse Madness
aware of what happened in one Division
and you have people who weren't and then
you also have curious cases like Moon
Knight it would seemingly go out of
their way to feel disconnected from the
MCU all while technically being part of
it say it with me
fragmentation the question then becomes
is it the fragmentation that's resulting
in potential dilution the notion that
reduction of quality in the MCU that
people are Keen to acknowledge now is a
product of the MCU having to satisfy a
fragmented audience across two different
storytelling mediums streaming and film
I don't have any concrete data for you
but if You observe all the things that
started off great and progressively
became less interesting or weaker as
time went along they've all been victims
of their own success which is a
philosophical Paradox of the highest
order in my opinion you can make a
strong argument that the MCU will soon
have the same problem Star Wars does as
its original fan base gets older the
unlikelihood of being able to satisfy
everyone so that talks sick MCU fan base
will then evolve from one that hated
everything because it wasn't the MCU to
hating the MCU that wasn't the original
MCU they grew up on it's all endlessly
fascinating I'll give you a bit of
production behind the scenes here um
this video you're watching right now was
a conversation we wanted to explore
before San Diego Comic-Con and given
everything Kevin feige mapped out for
phases five and six I feel it only
further contributes to this conversation
I want to have with all of you I'm
certain there's a section of the fan
base vehemently waiting for the entry of
the Fantastic Four Doctor Doom X-Men and
Secret Wars and they also probably think
that that will reinvigorate the MCU and
make it great again but you should be
very open to the possibility that they
may just make a greater case for the
conversation of the MCU diluting itself
because there's only two things that are
undefeated father time and being a
victim of your your own success actually
let's add a third and feeling like utter
trash after consuming large calories of
fast food for good measure I'm looking
forward to reading all the comments and
seeing how you contribute to this
conversation below even if you are the
most die-hard MCU fan do you ever feel
overwhelmed with the sheer volume of
content do you ever feel that it's
becoming somewhat of a chore to keep up
with everything if you are locked in a
room and could watch one MCU film while
having any fast food of your choice what
would it be okay let me shut up and get
out of here because I'll just start
doing rapid fire questions and then this
video will never end all right I'm out
for real I'll talk to y'all on the next
video goodbye